ALEX MAIER: Hello, everybody
and welcome.
My name is Alex Maier.
I am the community manager for
Google Cloud Platform.
And we're here today to talk
about getting started with the
Google Cloud Platform.
With me in the studio today
in Mountain View is Martin
Omander, who will take you
through a brief introduction
to how the Starter Pack works.
And then we're going to switch
over to London where Mandy
Waite is standing by to walk you
through the first steps to
getting to your very
first Hello World.
So Martin, good morning.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good
morning, Alex.
ALEX MAIER: How you doing?
MARTIN OMANDER: It was an early
morning this morning,
but I'm hanging in there.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
With enough coffee,
we can do it.
So let's dive right into this.
Can you tell us a little bit
about how the Cloud Platform
Starter Pack works?
MARTIN OMANDER: Sure, Alex.
The Starter Pack gives
developers a $2,000 credit for
the Cloud Platform, so you can
get started writing your
applications and try
out the platform.
So $2,000.
$1,000 is on App Engine and
$1,000 on Compute Engine.
And I know many of
you have already
requested these credits.
If you haven't yet, and you want
to request credits, you
can go to
cloud.google.com/starterpack.
Let me take that again.
It's early in the morning.
And then you enter the
promo code GDLSP-IN.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
So I have my Starter Pack.
I have the credits applied
to my account.
Now what?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
So now once you've received an
email from us that the credits
have been applied
in your account.
You now have credits
in two buckets.
You have the App Engine bucket
and the Compute Engine bucket.
And as you use App Engine or
Compute Engine, these credits
will be used up.
And as long as you have credits
left in either of
those two buckets, your bill
will look the same except that
credits will be used
up rather than us
charging your credit card.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
So where--
how do I see how many
credits I got left?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Unfortunately, there isn't a
good way of seeing exactly how
many you have left.
ALEX MAIER: Aw.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Working on that.
But--
so first off, App Engine
has a free usage tier.
So if you're only developing on
App Engine, chances are you
won't use App Engine enough for
there even to be charges.
Then for Compute Engine,
there's no free tier.
But as you use App Engine, you
get real users on App Engine
or use Compute Engine, you
will see your bills.
You will see charges start to
add up, except you won't
actually be charged yourself.
And then the way to see how
much you have left--
you have to take the $1,000 and
then subtract what you see
on your bills.
And that's how you
can calculate.
And if all of this is confusing,
you can always
email us at cloudplatformsta
rterpack@google.com.
And we'll look it up.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
Did you guys get that?
cloudplatformsta
rterpack@google.com if you have
any questions about how
much money you got left in
your credit account.
So what happens if I run out of
credits, because I'm using
so much Google Cloud Platform?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
When you run out of credits,
then your credit card will
start to get charged,
just like a normal
account at that point.
So you want to make sure you
use best development
practices, so that you preserve
your credits and your
money later on.
And we have plenty of
documentation on that in the
App Engine docs and in the
Compute Engine docs.
And maybe we'll hear some of
those best practices from
Mandy as well.
ALEX MAIER: Cool.
Thank you, Martin.
So guys, if you're listening,
and you have questions about
Starter Pack or using up your
credits, you can ask them in
the moderator box below.
And we're going to address the
questions at the end of this
streaming event.
But now, we're going to switch
to our London studio, where we
have Mandy Waite standing by.
Hi, Mandy.
MANDY WAITE: Hi, Alex.
How are you doing?
ALEX MAIER: I'm doing
very well.
Thank you.
How are you?
MANDY WAITE: I'm very
good today.
Thank you.
ALEX MAIER: So Mandy Waite is
a developer advocate for
Google Cloud Platform.
And she's going to walk us
through the steps to get from
zero to Hello World on Google
App Engine first.
Take it away.
MANDY WAITE: Thanks, Alex.
That's great.
OK.
So what I'm going to do--
I'm going to share my screen in
the Hangout and hope that
we'll have no technical
abnormalities that occur.
Hopefully, I can still see you
rather well, so while I'm
speaking and going through the
steps to getting started.
If anything abnormal occurs,
please wave at me.
So I'm going to share
my screen right now.
MARTIN OMANDER: And we're
not seeing the screen.
ALEX MAIER: We're not seeing
the screen yet.
There it is.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
MANDY WAITE: All righty then.
So can you guys hear me?
ALEX MAIER: We can.
MARTIN OMANDER: We're
seeing the Hangout.
ALEX MAIER: We're seeing
your Hangout, not
yet the demo window.
MANDY WAITE: OK.
That's fine.
I'm sharing my desktop currently
because we have
multiple windows to use.
So I'm going to switch over to a
terminal window just to make
sure that clears correctly.
That's great.
OK.
So I won't be coming back to
this screen very often.
But I will be using various
aspects of my desktop.
So to begin, most of the time
when you're working with App
Engine, you'll be
writing code.
There's a little bit of
stuff you have to do.
You do need to install the App
Engine SDK to begin with.
So let's do that first.
Now the App Engine SDK can
be downloaded from
developers.googl
e.com/appengine/downloads
So for this demonstration, we're
going to use Python.
This download page offers
a variety of options for
download of SDKs, different
program managers that would
support from App Engine, PHP,
Python, Java and Go and also
for different platforms.
So let's scroll down the list
of options we have.
So first we have Google App
Engine SDK for PHP.
PHP runtime is an experimental
feature in App Engine, and
it's currently limited
preview.
So in order to be able to use
it, you have to sign up.
So I'm going to skip
past that.
The next option is the Google
App Engine SDK for Python.
And we have three options
here, three different
platforms, one for Windows,
one for Mac OS X, and the
other one for Linux and
other Unix platforms.
Next, we have Java.
And the Java SDK is a
Java application.
And it requires JDK 7 in
order to terminate.
But that means you can manage
on platform support as well.
And the Google App Engine SDK
for Go supports three
platforms--
Linux, Mac OS, Windows, and 64
and 32-bit versions of those.
We're going to be focusing on
development for Python today.
So I'm going to-- well, I've
already downloaded the Google
App Engine launcher, which is
what the SDK is called for
some strange reason.
And it could take several
minutes to download.
So I've downloaded it already.
Once it's downloaded, you'll see
the image will be mounted.
And you will be shown the Google
App Engine Manager.
We can then drag that App
Engine Manager to our
Applications folder
on the Mac OS.
And we can then initially launch
the Google App Engine
Manager from the Applications
folder.
What we're going to be doing
mostly is working with command
line though.
So we don't need to worry too
much about the App Manager
application.
But I want to show it to you
anyway because on Mac OS we
have some interesting paths,
where these tools, these
command line tools
are installed to.
The App Engine Manager can
actually help us make those
more accessible.
So when you install the Google
App Engine Manager, it prompts
you to install symbolic
links to the various
command line tools.
If you've ignored that step and
then skipped past it, then
you might want to go and do it
at some point because it makes
it much easier to get
access to the tools.
And in order to do it, go to
Google App Engine Manager, and
the Menu Items and select
Make Symlinks.
The App Engine Launcher can
be used to deploy your
applications to App Engine and
to also run them locally on
your local machine.
App Engine comes with
a development
server which forms locally.
And we're going to talk more
about that and actually show
you that run-through shortly.
So that's the last time we're
actually going to use the
Google App Engine launcher.
On Windows, things are
pretty much the same.
Once you've installed the
application, the SDK
application from its installer,
all of the command
line utilities will be available
in the path for you.
And for Linux or other Unix
systems, you'll untar the
tarball distribution
of the SDK.
And then you'll have to add
manually the paths to those
command line tools to your
environment path.
So next step we're going to
do is develop some code.
And this is fairly
straightforward.
We're going to cd into my
Hello World directory.
This is a very simple
application.
It just prints Hello World
out in the web browser.
And the first thing we're going
to look at is the actual
code itself.
And this is platform code.
And if I can get it in advanced,
it makes it easier
to actually manage
the screen cast.
So the code is pretty simple.
There's not many lines
of code here.
The first thing to do is import
webapp2, which is the
simple WSDL web application
framework.
We're going to need that to do
the rest of the commands in
this particular Python script.
Then we have to create
a class.
This is going to be
an instance of a
webapp2 request handler.
We can call it anything
we like.
In this case, we call
it main page.
But it must implement the
webapp2 request handler.
Another request handler.
Its responsibility is to process
incoming requests.
And we have to provide methods
for the various HTTP methods.
In this case, we've
implemented get.
That's a very simple method.
It has two lines of code.
One is second headers on
the response stream.
That sets the content type
header out to the text plane.
And we're actually going to
write HTML code here.
We're going to put some plain
text straight to the browser.
And the second command actually
writes Hello World,
exclamation mark, to the
response stream.
And that's pretty much all
the application code.
The last thing we have to do is
actually declare this as a
WSDL application.
And we're going to call
it application.
We could call it anything.
But we do have to use that name
consistently throughout
the application development.
And the WSDL application
basically maps a URL path to
this request handler.
In this case, it's mapping the
URL path slash to main page,
which is the class that
we created earlier.
So that's the actual
Python code.
There's also another bit
of code we need to do.
It's basically a configuration
file.
And it's called app.yaml.
And app.yaml is the key to all
App Engine applications.
And it's what App Engine
requires to actually
understand your application.
So we're going to actually edit
the one we have already
created earlier.
So basically, this file,
app.yaml, will inform the App
Engine runtime about your
application, provide some
information about your
application and how to handle
requests that come into
that application.
The first thing we have to
do is provide a name, an
application name.
So this is the application
domain.
And in this case, we've called
it Hobbit-Frog-123.
Now the reason this is a
complicated name is because
this is the actual application
name we're going to want to
refer to later in App Engine.
And these have to be unique.
So I've chosen an
arbitrary name.
But in App Engine, you can
actually give it some title
that's meaningful to you.
So while you're running in the
development environment, it's
actually possible to use
any kind of name here.
But for consistency, let's
make things simple.
I've used the application name
we're going to deploy to.
You also have to provide
a version
number or version string.
This doesn't have
to be a number.
In this case, we're in
the same version 1.
But it could be version
demo, version test.
You also have to specify the
runtime you want to use within
App Engine.
And of course, this is
a Python application.
So we're using Python 2.7.
Now there's also a Python
option, which
maps to Python 2.5.
But that's been deprecated,
and we shouldn't use it.
The API version is generally
always one.
So you can consider this pretty
much to be boilerplate
code, unless instructed
otherwise.
And finally, we have to tell App
Engine if the applications
is thread-safe or not.
And what this allows App Engine
to do is to basically
use one single instance of the
application to serve as
multiple requests
simultaneously.
If your application is not
thread-safe, you need to make
sure this is set to false.
Then App Engine will make sure
that only one request is being
served by an instance
at any given time.
One of the most important parts
of this configuration
file is the mapping of URL
paths to handlers.
And that only appears in
the Handler section.
Here, we're mapping a
URL path, which is a
complete wild card.
We can map any path to
a script, which is
helloworld.application.
And this, effectively, is the
Hello World module that we
created for an application
as we saw in the
helloworld.qr file.
So that's basically what we
need for an App Engine
application, two basic files.
So next thing we're going to do,
we'll actually want to run
that application.
We want to run it locally.
We'll test it and see if it
works correctly before
actually deploying
it to App Engine.
So this is fairly
straightforward.
Having installed the SDK and
going through the steps to
create Symlinks using the App
Engine Launcher, we should
have access to those commands
in the path.
And in this case, I'm going
to use a command called
devappserver.py.
And this has a bunch
of options.
But we're going to use a very
simple command line syntax,
which basically just requires
that we pass in the directory
or folder where the output YAML
file that belongs to the
application lives.
And in this case, we're in
that directory already.
So we can just say,
devappserver.py.
But that could be some arbitrary
path somewhere else
in the file system.
So the development environment
is very conscientious.
It wants to know even once to
actually check for updates
when we start up.
We're going to say yes
because we want to
keep up with updates.
App Engine tends to update
about once a month.
So now we've started our
development environment.
That will be laying on port
8080 on our local machine.
So let's go have a check there
and see if everything works as
we hoped it will.
Ah, so nginx is running.
Hold on.
I thought I closed nginx.
So I seem to have a problem with
my Mac where nginx seems
to start up on its own.
It seems to go away.
As soon as you remove it, it
seems to fire up again.
So we've actually basically
mapped the port we're going to
use for our DevApp server.
It should be 9090
instead of 8080.
So hopefully, that
will solve that
particular problem for us.
And there we are, Hello World.
So we've successfully developed
a very, very simple
Python application.
One great thing about doing
it this way with the local
development environment is
that we can iteratively
develop our applications.
And I'll give you a quick
example of that.
If I create a new shell
window here.
I will cd into our Hello World
directory where our files are.
And I will modify the
Python script.
We'll change the message
to be something
a little bit different.
So now I'll change the script.
And we go back to our web
browser, refresh the screen.
And we see that that's
instantly updated.
Now what we can do is
iteratively develop our
application, make changes, and
see them instantly reflected
in the development
environment.
And that really allows for very,
very agile testing in
development work.
So once we've actually made
all the changes we need to
make to our application, we want
to deploy to App Engine.
Currently, it's running
on our local machine.
We want to deploy
to App Engine.
So the first thing we're going
to need to do is go to the App
Engine console.
And the App Engine console
is located at
appengine.google.com.
And what you see when you visit
appengine.google.com--
it'll probably depend
on what user you've
logged into Google Apps.
Each user that's signed up for
App Engine will see a list of
the applications that they own,
that they've actually
created, and the applications
they've been given
permission to run.
In this case, we see two
applications, including the
applications I created
earlier, one called
Hobbit-Frog-123, which
is the application I
want to deploy to.
And that's actually called
credits amount.
When you click on create
application for the first time
when you visit this page, you
will probably be prompted to
verify your identity by an SMS
message or voice call.
Create an Applications, fairly
straightforward.
You provide a unique application
identifier, if
you're using the appspot.com.
You do have the option to use
a Google Apps name, in which
case you can use any
name that's unique
in your app's name.
And you also have to provide
an application title.
Authentication options--
we're not going to actually
create an account here.
But we have various options.
And you can click on learn more
in the screen to find out
more about those options.
We've already created our
applications, so we don't need
to worry about that
particular step.
So Hobbit-Frog-123 is the name
of our application, and that
is unique in the appspot.com
namespace.
So let's shut down
our development
server, Control C that.
And now we want to deploy the
application to App Engine.
And to do that, we use another
command, another utility
command called appcfg.py.
And appcfg.py has various
functions.
It performs all of the options
for deploying your application
to App Engine.
And then it can make management
features as well.
So it's quite a powerful tool.
We're going to use it very
simply to update our
application.
We haven't actually
installed it yet.
But we use the update command.
And we have to provide the path
to the directory that
contains the app.yaml file.
And again, that's the same
path that we have now.
So appfg.py update dot.
Hit Return on that.
So this is the first time I've
deployed this application.
And this is maybe the first time
I've used App Engine on
this particular machine.
And it's going to prompt
me for my credentials.
In this case, it's going to
prompt me for my email address
and my password.
If I had two factor
authentications set up on this
account, I could also provide
an application specific
password instead of my
actual password.
There's also another option
as well, which is to use
minus, minus 002.
And this is the mechanism I
would recommend you to use
because this performs a
[INAUDIBLE] flow, will pop up
the browser, and display an
acceptance dialog box to
accept what permissions
appcfg.py is requesting.
And that's the best way
to authenticate.
But for the simplest form, it's
basically just providing
your email and password,
which we'll do now.
And so now it looks for files
in the directory where the
app.yaml is.
It reads the app.yaml and it
basically uploads and moves
the files to App Engine.
Then it checks to see if the
deployment was successful.
Then it checks that the app
version is actually certain.
Once it's performed those
checks, it'll come back to us
and say the application's
been updated.
Now we should be able to go to
that application and actually
see it running.
So let's try that.
So using the Google App Engine
admin console, we can actually
go straight to our application
by checking on the link at the
very end in the last column
after the status column.
There we are.
Hello, Mandy.
It's been deployed.
ALEX MAIER: Wonderful.
MANDY WAITE: And that's pretty
much what you need to do to
get started with App Engine.
ALEX MAIER: Cool.
Thank you so much, Mandy.
This is really cool and pretty
easy to follow even for me.
And I'm kind of new to this.
Now if I wanted to add Compute
Engine to the mix, what do you
suggest I do?
MANDY WAITE: Well, so I'm going
to have to go and turn
the lights on in the studio
because the light's turned off
now while I was doing
the demo.
So if you'll bear with me--
this is really live, guys.
I'm going to go and turn
the lights on.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
While we wait for Mandy--
All right.
She's back.
That was quick.
MANDY WAITE: So basically,
I wasn't moving enough.
If I'd been moving enough, the
lights would have stayed on.
OK.
So what was your question
again, Alex?
ALEX MAIER: So what would you
do if you wanted to add
Compute Engine to this since
we have credits for both?
Gotta burn them.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
Well, Compute Engine's a
little bit different.
It doesn't serve applications.
It doesn't serve webapps the
way App Engine does.
So we have to work it a
little bit different.
But it's pretty much as simple
as it was with App Engine.
So let's go through
that process now.
I'll share my screen
again with you.
Fingers crossed, everything's
going to go smoothly
this time as well.
ALEX MAIER: There you go.
MANDY WAITE: Yes.
There you go indeed.
OK.
So I'm going to switch to a
different browser this time
because I'm logged into two
different accounts.
The first thing you need to do
in order to get started with
Compute Engine is to download
its powerful
utility called gcutil.
And that's what we're
going to do first.
So let's go to the
developers.com page that
actually hosts that.
Oh, look.
It's already in my path.
So developers.googl
e.com/compute/docs/gcutil is
the path that you need.
And we'll put all of these links
in the comments for the
YouTube video when we post it.
We'll go to that page.
And this page is
really useful.
It describes how gcutil works.
It gives you all of the
information about how to
download and install it.
It also gives you information
about authenticating, which is
always useful.
So this tool is really useful
for you as a reference for
getting started with gcutil.
But gcutil is basically
the management
tool for Compute Engine.
It allows you to create compute
resources within
Compute Engine.
It allows you to create virtual
machines, networks,
disks, and that kind of thing.
What we need to do is
install gcutil.
So the first thing we need
to do is download it.
And that's pretty quick.
It's not a particularly
big file.
Most of the work it does is done
at the back end in the
Compute Engine, so it's
pretty small.
We'll open that up.
And then we'll cd into
the location where
we downloaded it.
And there we have it.
So this is gcutil.
The most important files in
this particular directory
structure--
this is the uncompressed version
of the files that
we've just downloaded.
You'll find gcutil, which is the
script, the Python script
that actually is the
heart of gcutil.
And also, there's a library
directory, which contains all
the libraries that gcutil
needs to run.
And there's also a make
file as well.
The make file can be used on
systems that have Developer
Tools installed, for example,
Ace Code on the Mac.
And you can just do make install
to install gcutil and
the libraries into /usershare,
and also to make a symbolic
link into /user/bin
for gcutil.
We don't have the rights on this
machine to actually run
that, to do that.
So I'm going to do another
bit of a trick.
We're going to add to my path
the current directory.
Now I can say which gcutil
to find out where it is.
And there it is.
So we're going to use gcutil
quite extensively throughout
this particular run-through,
and we need it
available on our paths.
That's available to us.
We can actually run
help with gcutil.
And we can list all of the
options, all of the sub
commands that it offers us.
As you can see, it's
quite extensive.
And it gives us the ability to
create instances, create
networks, to create snapshots
and persistent disks, and to
perform all of the
administration
tasks within a project.
And as you've probably applied
your credits and created a
project within Google Cloud
Console, you'll understand
what a project is.
A project is a grouping of
compute resources like virtual
machines and networks.
And so gcutil effectively works
at the project level.
And in order to make it useful
to us, when we first run it,
we need to provide
a project name.
Some of this can be cached
locally on the disk.
But we do need to provide a
project name to tell it what
project to use.
So what I need to do is go into
the Cloud Console and
find my project, which in this
case is Cloud Demos.
And it has another interesting
name, [INAUDIBLE]
Pointer-309.
And we'll use that as
the project ID.
So once you run gcutil,
we're basically
parsing the project ID.
And then we provide a command.
Now what we want to
do is actually--
we want to create a new
instance, a new Compute Engine
virtual machine.
So we use the add instance
command to do this.
And we're going to create an
instance called My Instance.
I'm very inventive that way,
coming up with new names.
So we run gcutil and
add instance.
But we're just running
this arbitrarily
in our command line.
We want to connect to this
project called [INAUDIBLE]
Pointer-309.
And it doesn't know
who we are.
So we need to provide some
kind of verification.
And what it does-- it pops up a
URL, which you can then copy
and paste into the browser in
which you are running, which
you are logged in as that
particular account you want to
authenticate as.
And I have to be very careful
here not to actually shut down
the Hangout.
I'm sure that would cause
us real problems.
So now Compute Engine.
Well, the [INAUDIBLE] mechanism
will present you
with a list of permissions that
the gcutil tool would
like to have.
What you should do is you should
review these permission
requests and make sure you're
happy with them.
Once you are, you can
click on Accept.
That now provides your code that
you can use to cut and
paste into your terminal
window.
And it will say, authentication
successful.
Now gcutil will execute the
add instance command.
And it's going to walk us
through a set of four
menus in this case.
We can provide more parameters
in the command line to
actually specify all of these.
So we can actually do it
silently with no interaction.
But let's go through the
interactive method because
that gives us an idea of what
options are available to us.
So the first thing we need to
do is select a zone in which
the instance will run.
And this gives us some useful
information about when
somebody's engine will
be mentioned.
We wouldn't want to pick your
dash [INAUDIBLE] dash B
because that starts a
[INAUDIBLE] within two days.
So let's pick US Central 1-A.
Now we have to specify
a machine type.
And machine type is basically
a configuration of hardware
for a virtual machine.
We're going to choose a very
simple one, which is a shared
call instance called f1-micro.
This is the smallest instance
you can get and
the cheapest to run.
Now, if you want to do some
testing, you want to save
yourself some of your credits,
I recommend that you always
use an f1-micro for doing
your testing.
You can create huge clusters of
f1-micros, but they don't
incur a huge amount of cost
while they're running.
For this particular instance,
we have to create what is
known as a persistent disk.
Other options have a scratch
disk, which is tied to the
life of the virtual machine.
In this case, we actually have
to create a project level
persistent disk that will be
associated with our instance.
And finally, we have to choose
an image, initial image of a
Linux operating system.
The options we have are
[INAUDIBLE] six, and
[INAUDIBLE] six and
[INAUDIBLE] seven.
I like [INAUDIBLE], and
I like version seven.
So I'm going to choose that.
So now gcutil is actually
communicating--
has actually communicated its
commands to the API, the
Compute Engine API.
And now it's sitting here
waiting for that API to come
back with a response.
So the first thing it's doing
is inserting the disk called
My Instance.
It's actually created
that name itself.
We've named our instance My
Instance, so it makes sense to
name the boot disk.
OK.
The boot disk.
Sometimes you get this prompt,
and hopefully it's just going
to carry on going afterwards.
So now it's inserted the disk.
And so that will insert
the instance.
So they're both going to
be called My Instance.
And that was the point I was
trying to make before, that
the disk is automatically named
after the instance.
And that's complete.
We're done.
We've created an instance.
And we can now SSH into
that instance.
Again, we're going to reuse the
command we used before, at
least part of it, gcutil
management project,
[INAUDIBLE]
Pointer-309.
We could actually-- as I said
before, we could actually
cache some of this information
on a local machine.
But in this case, we're just
going to go ssh my instance.
Now gcutil and Compute Engine
take care of all of the SSH
keys for you.
So you don't have to
worry about that.
And you can use your own
keys if you want to.
That's the most important
part.
So the key management is done
by Compute Engine normally.
But you can actually supply
your own SSH keys.
So now we're actually logged
into My Instance.
And we can see maybe
what processes are
running on that instance.
And what we can do-- because
it's a Linux instance.
It's an instance
of [INAUDIBLE].
We can actually install
some software.
So let's install nginx.
Nginx is a web server, a very
popular web server.
And that's what we're going to
use to serve our Hello World.
So this is pretty standard,
apt-get.
Anybody who's installed a
package on a Linux machine,
you've very familiar
with this.
And now we need to start
our service, nginx.
And nginx is now started.
And you can actually check
that it's running.
And there you go.
It's running.
More detail.
OK.
So now we have nginx
up and running.
We need to create a file
that's going to
display Hello World.
So let's use [INAUDIBLE]
to--
my favorite editor--
to create a new index.html
file.
And again, well, let's put
some HTML in this time.
We'll call it H1,
use a H1 tag.
And we will say, Hello World.
OK.
So now we created
our index.html.
And we need to copy
it over to nginx.
Sorry.
I've forgotten where it is,
so I need to find it.
OK.
So I need to copy this file
that we've just created,
index.html, over to
/user/share/nginx/www.
And because that's not going
to be owned by me,
I need to use sudo.
And I'll copy index.html.
There we go.
That's done.
So now what we need to do is
find out the instance in our
IP address so then we
can connect to it.
We're not using DNS here.
We haven't set up anything
for DNS.
So we need to actually
know the IP address.
And for that, I'm just going to
quickly exit the instance.
I'm going to use gcutil again to
get some information about
the instance.
And this gives us all of the
metadata information about the
instance that's actually
been built and running.
In this case, it provides us
with the IP address, the
external IP address.
This is the IP address that was
ephemerally assigned to
the instance, and which we can
access the instance by.
I have a thing we need to do
because by default, we have
firewall rules in place that
prevents access to the
instance by any other port other
than port 22, which is
the SSH port.
So we need to actually
add a firewall.
So we're going to add a firewall
rule that allows us
to access our HTTP server
on port 80.
And that's going to
be called HTTP1.
And it's going to be--
so now it's creating
a firewall for us.
And this is going to be a
project level resource.
So this has opened up that port
for one of our instances.
And that's done.
So now, we can take the
external IP address.
And fingers crossed--
have you got your
fingers crossed, Alex?
Excellent.
OK.
Hello, World.
There you go.
ALEX MAIER: And again, folks, if
you have any questions for
Mandy, you can put them in
the moderator box below.
We'll go through them.
We also will have a recording
of this video available.
And we will post it on
this page later.
So you can visit and
re-watch that.
Also, I am hearing that the
video quality, particularly
the screen share, has been
deteriorating sometimes.
And we will be redoing
this later on.
And we hope that video quality
will be better at that point.
So first, I wanted to ask both
of you, Martin and Mandy, do
you have any tips and tricks
for people actually getting
the best out of their $2,000 and
not burning through them
in a hurry?
Mandy?
MANDY WAITE: Yeah, definitely.
So Martin and I were talking
about this yesterday.
So one of the key things
you should do is cache.
You should cache everything.
Anything that hits the App
Engine instances will use
instance hours, and that will
eat into your [INAUDIBLE],
ultimately, which carries
on and that will
eat into your credits.
So you want to avoid
hitting the
instances, so static content.
You can also cache dynamically
generated responses as well by
using cache control headers.
You can also cache your data
store reads as well because
data store access is relatively
expensive in terms
of quality usage.
So whenever you read anything
from the data store that's
likely to be read again by
multiple user requests or just
multiple times throughout
processing your own requests,
you should cache
it in MemCache.
And we have a really good
MemCache cache implementation,
a Google wide service,
that you can use
to cache your reads.
What else, Martin?
I think that--
one thing I mentioned for
Compute Engine is that--
I'm running instances
currently.
My instances are up and running,
like the one I
created earlier, My Instance.
That will ultimately
cost money.
That will ultimately eat into
your credits because it's
sitting there doing nothing.
It's idle.
And we don't want to have idle
instances sitting around in
Compute Engine.
So you saw me create a f1-micro
instance earlier.
That's the smallest, cheapest
instance you can use.
So I'd highly recommend you use
those for test purposes,
for development purposes.
And when you're finished
with them, tear them
down, shut them down.
There's a gcutil command called
delete instance that
will delete your instances
for you.
And you can actually run and
do that using the Cloud
Console as well.
Anything else, Martin?
MARTIN OMANDER: No.
Just echo what you
said about cache.
I often see developers--
for every page request, they go
down and hit the database
and pull out the data.
And 99% of the time, you are
reading data, not writing it.
So then just put
it in MemCache.
Not only will you spend less
credits and less money, but
your application will be
significantly faster if you
use MemCache instead
of hitting the
database every time.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
Mandy, do you happen to have
any resources that can get
people from their Hello World
to the next level?
MANDY WAITE: I think what we're
going to do is we're
going to post those with links
in the YouTube comments
because I don't have them
available to me at the moment.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
So guys, come back
to this page.
And we'll have more
links there.
I'm going to turn to the
questions on the
moderator right now.
The number one question is,
can I use a debit card to
activate my account?
Martin?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
You should be able to
use a debit card.
I've tried it.
Now, I don't know--
I think this question was
from the Netherlands.
I don't know the details of how
debit cards work there.
But in general, if it's a debit
card that says Visa or
MasterCard, something like
that, on it, you
should able to do it.
ALEX MAIER: All right.
That's all the questions
we have at the moment.
If you think of any more
questions, not to worry.
You can still share them with
us, and we will answer them.
Simply email them to
cloudplatformsta
rterpack@google.com.
And with that, thank you very
much, Mandy and Martin.
Thank you all for listening
and attending.
Good bye.
MANDY WAITE: Thanks Alex.
Bye.
MARTIN OMANDER: Bye.